the new atheism has become a laughing
stock and I mean that literally people
are literally laughing at the motherload
of dumb ideas the new atheism if you
don't know what the new atheism is it's
atheism with a severe attitude problem a
very poor grasp of human nature and what
I can only call communal narcissistic
personality disorder atheists 30 or 40
years ago usually didn't care much about
what other people believed but when the
new atheists came along after 9/11
people like Richard Dawkins and
Christopher Hitchens and Sam Harris
convinced a generation of young atheists
that religion is about to destroy the
world unless atheists put an end to it
by spending every waking moment on
social media typing Sky daddy Sky daddy
Sky daddy Sky daddy Sky Daddy but the
new atheism came with a powerful and
testable prediction the prediction was
this if we can just get millions of
people to abandon Christianity in the
west Western Society will become more
rational more scientific more
enlightened so to test this prediction
millions of people left
Christianity did Society become more
rational more scientific more
enlightened no the Western World went
completely insane and people are
starting to notice in a recent interview
with onag off again richest man in the
world Elon Musk Jordan Peterson
presented his hypothesis about what
happens when a predominantly Christian
Society starts to abandon Christian
monotheism spoiler alert he doesn't
think that abandoning Christian
monotheism is going to make Society more
rational more scientific more
enlightened okay so imagine this imagine
that there's a a Unity of moral purpose
yeah that is conceptualized in the
traditional writings as what should be
put in the highest place so it's God and
in in the final analysis it's ineffable
but it is a fundamental uni unification
of monotheism Christian monotheism
provides a Unity of moral purpose
there's a standard of good and bad right
and wrong there's something to aim
towards there's the sacrificial love of
Jesus as an ideal there's a Transcendent
reference point
the new atheists come along and say hey
get rid of that
nonsense okay then what happens let me
guess scientific
Utopia here's a hypothesis when that
collapses two things arise to replace it
okay one is the striving for power and
the other is the untrammeled what would
you call it the untr Dominion of
Hedonism and Es especially on the sexual
gratification side when people turn away
from The Pursuit Of God what makes you
think the pursuit of God will be
replaced by the pursuit of
science that could be true for some
people living in the Ivor EST of Ivory
Towers Oxford but here on planet reality
when people turn away from the pursuit
of God the pursuit of God is replaced by
the pursuit of power or pleasure so it's
like if there's no ultimate un
that's future and Community oriented
that's predicated on sacrifice you get a
dissolution immediately into the next
two contenders for Domination and one is
it's about me buddy and get the hell out
of the way and aligned with that is not
only is it about me it's about me uh
what would you say subjugated to my most
base whims because why would I want
Power except to do exactly what the hell
I want whenever I want to Peterson put
this forward as a hypothesis if you
abandon God God will be replaced by
power or by Pleasure the hypothesis of
the new atheist was that if you abandon
God God will be replaced by science or
Reason look around you and tell me which
hypothesis has massive confirmation and
which hypothesis has massive
disconfirmation are people striving for
more careful and accurate reasoning
about the world they live in or are they
striving ring for more power and control
over others and more unrestrained
satisfaction of their
desires and the new atheists think
Christians are the ones with a
delusion and so part of the problem with
the idea of people like Dawkins so
Dawkins and the atheists I've had many
conversations with Dawkins over the
years you have oh yeah yeah oh we're
going to do a podcast together okay
which I'm very looking forward to oh I'm
looking forward to that too imagine
spending Decades of your life blasting
away at Christianity only to wake up one
day and finally realize that you played
a crucial role in destroying your own
culture and your own
country but on the bright side if people
didn't dedicate their entire lives to
attacking Christianity they might not
have anything to regret when they see
their civilization come crashing to the
ground but I'm I'm very curious about
this issue because his idea and it's
kind of an enlightenment idea is that we
dispensed with the idiot Superstition of
the past then everyone would become you
know bonian rationalists and that seem
yeah unfortunately not why did Elon Musk
laugh we dispensed with the idiot
Superstition of the past then everyone
would become you know bonian
rationalists and that seemed yeah how
does Elon Musk who doesn't really
believe in Christianity instantly
recognize the Ridiculousness the idiocy
the insanity of the new atheist
position I'm not sure I don't know if
he's always had a greater understanding
of human nature than the new atheists
who have none or if he just gets it now
because he's seen what's happened over
the past two decades either way one of
the core beliefs of the new atheists is
now something for people to laugh at
because it's embarrassingly stupid
on a side note Peterson says that
Dawkins thought that when people
abandoned religion they would become
bonian
rationalists I wouldn't consider Francis
Bacon a rationalist at least not in the
philosophical sense of rationalist
versus empiricist bacon is sometimes
called the father of empiricism he's one
of the pioneers of the scientific
method I think Peterson might be using
the term rationalist in a broader sense
but
I'm not sure Dawkins would want people
to become baconian rationalists bacon
after all is the one who said I dare
affirm in knowledge of nature that a
little natural philosophy natural
philosophy is what they called science
back then I dare affirm in knowledge of
nature that a little natural philosophy
and the first entrance into it does
dispose the opinion to atheism but on
the other side much natural philosophy
and waiting deep into it will bring
about men's Minds to religion wherefore
atheism every way seems to be combined
with Folly and ignorance seeing nothing
can be more justly allotted to the
saying of fools than this there is no
God that bacon is
sizzling but I'm nitpicking we all
understand what Peterson means Dawkins
thought and possibly still thinks that
if people drop their silly superstitions
they'll become more scientifically
minded and to that we all
say yeah unfortunately not somebody buy
that Laughing Man a cyber truck no well
what seems to me to happen much more
likely is that power and Hedonism rise
to take the place of what was holy so to
speak you know and n warned about that
when he proclaimed the death of God to
begin with he thought nihilism would Al
enter the realm right nihilism power and
Hedonism as the as the triumvirate of
replacement Gods nihilism power and
Hedonism n saw it coming the Germans had
a better understanding of the
implications of rejecting God than the
British did the Germans said we're
getting rid of God and we're going to
need something really really big to
replace him or we're going to be in a
lot of trouble the British said we're
getting rid of God jolly good show dkan
says we all be fine is't
it but the Germans never did find the
replacement that n was looking for so
the Germans and the British are now all
in the same Pub they're sharing a
cocktail made of onep part nihilism two
parts Hedonism and a dash of power which
keeps them too drunk to stay stand
against the weakest invasion in
history but don't worry I'm sure that
scientific Utopia the new atheists have
so much Blind Faith in is right around
the
corner in fantasy land
[Music]